boy to explain what a production
designer does I think of myself as the
hand of the director I read a script
absorb all that information but my real
job is to understand how the director
reads the script and what he sees and
what he wants to visually accomplish and
you almost have to become I don't know
do you have to be a mind reader or you
just have to Intuit the director and
personality the director and where he
wants to go in pre-production you know
we're given the script and the budget
and we try to do the best we can to get
this the physical things than somebody's
home who's a character or any of the
sets whatever they would be from a
palace to a garbage dump I mean it's all
is everything gardens hotels all of it
and we there do a practical location and
change things according to our script or
we build it from scratch so we have it
just the way we want it the primary
responsibility is responding to the
script obviously then trying to make
your vision fit within the restraints of
any budget and thirdly I suppose is
maintaining a good working relationship
with the people around you which i think
is it's kind of quite high on the
priority list it's a lot of work and I
don't work alone I work with the group
and in the state so we have what we call
a lead man who runs my whole crew and
then we have set dressers who move all
the things around and I work with a
buyer and on a bigger project I have two
buyers and a coordinator it's it's a
very fast-paced operation it's never
boring though yeah I mean I think if
you're trying to create a world you
always need to be able to do it as
accurately as you possibly can and
that's when you rely heavily on a team
of people that around you that work in
my department without whom you know you
are only as good as the people that in
the team that you're working
I can say that with my hand on my heart
so they are really important part of the
whole process so you have a you cannot
quite often you know talk to them spend
hours researching that's the main part
of this job is getting good reference
it's the timing it's it's very it's I
guess you could call it interior
decorating
speed it up it's very fast pace we
usually pay attention to the first week
of shooting because things always change
they've changed schedules according to
actors availability or they've changed
the script so as soon as it's certain
what the first week of shooting will be
for a film we we want to be completely
100% ready for that at the end of
pre-production which is usually eight
weeks eight to ten weeks for an average
film you know from the time I was a
child I was somehow interested in the
theater and you know whether it was
acting or building sets and I can
remember you know as a kid a book a
Samuel French edition of wait until dark
and there was a diagram of the stage
that of the ground side of the stage
said back a book and I built a model of
that in a shoebox well I started off
doing a theater design degree and I
spent ten years doing theater where you
do everything I mean everything build
the set sometimes on low-budget stuff
you designed the costumes and then I
reached a point where I was sort of I
was in a transitional period with that
and a friend of mine said look do you
want to come and help me on these short
films so and we did everything out the
back of a van and we didn't go to high
shops we just skip hunted for props
eglee will tell you this one of the
reasons he was interested in my
designing Life of Pi was because of my
theater background and he had a sense
that shooting a film 3d to him felt
somewhat like
feeder the sort of the dimension of
theater and and the way perspective
works in theater so he kind of liked the
idea that that was my background that
that was where I came from well I think
multitasking is pretty important you
have to be able to have a lot going on
at once and not get rattled about it and
you know a lot of social skills and
getting along with anybody anywhere you
know you could be in a millionaire's
home you know and they come and visit
when you've changed it all and you have
to be able to appease them if they don't
like the way it looks and you know but
usually the location department works
with you about situations like that and
you just have to be able to fit into any
situation anywhere and try and be as
comfortable as possible about it and
it's you know that can be challenging
sometimes and sometimes it's a wonderful
surprise and you meet people that you
know for the rest of your life I think
my advice to anybody would be if you
really want to pursue it then don't stop
get as much experience as you can in any
field of any part of the filmmaking
business first of all you just have to
have it in your heart that just has to
be the way you see things that you read
a story or hear a story and you think of
it in visual terms I think the training
would be in art history and interior
design and full-on you know production
courses that would be available and
internships with a set decorator if
that's possible so you can shadow
somebody to really see what it's like
and if it would be for you you know I
think if you believe in something if you
if you love doing something enough
you'll get there anyway it's just a
matter of how you do it assist you know
getting assisting people getting your
way in and in any particular way phoning
up people like me you know knocking on
doors so if you have that in your heart
I think the things that you have to sort
of bear in mind is that you have to
be respectful of the stories that you
read and listen to your director so I
think if you could do that maybe control
a budget and you have it in your heart
to design that you'll have a successful
career